hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday September 2nd 2019 happy
[ __ ] Labor Day no why is he [ __ ]
wire saw why don't i untwist them before
I start the [ __ ] podcast nah that's
not what you like to do you got too much
[ __ ] Irish blood yes so what are you
doing god damn [ __ ] thing all right
is that better is that better on twisty
untwisting sorry happy Labor Day to
everybody out there that's actually got
a [ __ ] job and a lemon off of Uncle
Sam you know what I think I think on
Labor Day everybody was a job to get the
day off but anybody laying around like
these [ __ ] homeless people gonna be
sent to work stick that stinky
[ __ ] for underneath the bench
stick him in one of them [ __ ] ups
stores so I can mail out a thank-you
card for the 12-pack a [ __ ] pack Blue
Ribbon that was sent to me but my other
brother who has a [ __ ] job that's the
problem with these [ __ ] liberals
Labor Day weekend they they let
everybody celebrate it you should you
should prove that shirt you're gainfully
[ __ ] employed before you have one
simple Miller like this weekend how do
you prove it all you do is take off your
[ __ ] shades and people look in your
eye and they see that lifeless look and
they see your dream that died in the
middle of that [ __ ] big sorrowful
swim and pull a [ __ ] that you call a
pupil then they'll be like this man is a
working man I gotta admit man you know
every once in a while I do see a
homeless person and I'm tired and I just
I'm laying on the sidewalk sleeping and
you start thinking like you know I
[ __ ] love to be doing that right now
I wouldn't want to be homeless but I
would just I would love to just [ __ ]
lay down and take a nap right now and
that guy's doing it he's living his best
life what are you guys doing for Labor
Day week and I imagine you're doing it
right now huh
having a good time then you got a short
week then you got a short week and I
believe NFL football starts next week
college football started this weekend
with the college football kickoff Dallas
Cowboys Stadium and a woman it was a
barn burner the Alabama Crimson Tide
versus the Duke Blue Devils I know when
they started the broadcast the guy oh
we've been waiting a long time for this
one what he meant was for college
football to start he wasn't saying you
know as much as I enjoyed the past 150
year whatever the [ __ ] it is 100 years
of [ __ ] college football the one
thing that has been missing is I just
wish Duke would have Alabama on their
football schedule so we could finally
settle the argument of who is better I
will say though Duke played the first
quarter force that fumble they were
playing great and I know a lot of people
you should go and shoot kick the field
goal why'd you kick the field goal gate
get points get on the board that's what
I thought too I thought they should have
done that too just just to even just say
you at one point you were up three to
nothing like the New England Patriots
when he played the 85 Bears Tony
Franklin came in right kick that field
goal we were up three to nothing three I
told that story in the Edelman thing
which I still haven't even seen because
I don't have showtimes [ __ ] frequent
flyer whatever [ __ ] streaming service
my wife let me tell my wife she's
hilarious
oh yeah we have all of that stuff we
have Amazon whose Showtime oh my god
great and then I go to sit down I wanted
to watch Jim Gaffigan special on Amazon
we didn't have that Amazon Prime right
and then and then we didn't have the
show type thing so I have to add that to
my packages you know so I can be I
I want to be the person in America
paying the most for his [ __ ] Direct
TV because I know all you kids now you
just stream everything I'm old school if
I want a channel I call up the cable
company and I order it I think I pay
about nine hundred sixty-five dollars a
month in cable fees actually who the
[ __ ] was saying red band was saying he
was gonna come over my house and [ __ ]
figure out everything I was doing wrong
and get me down to about $38 a month and
I said that would be great and that was
the last time we ever spoke no I gotta
get him to come over here and figure
that [ __ ] out anyway congratulations to
Alabama starting I don't understand why
was that the kickoff classic why didn't
you make it
Auburn Oregon like every year they have
a you know so they're not all cupcake
games they have one game where it's two
ranked people coming out of the gate now
why doesn't Jerry Jones get that [ __ ]
game I'll tell you why cuz he's a
southerner and Alabama is just a little
bit further south than Duke & Duke has
that northern vibe to him you know
they're smart they brush their teeth you
know they can afford a haircut I mean
that just screams you know north of the
mason-dixon line all right you get those
country folks with that wild look in
their eye like I can't imagine you know
we should get a [ __ ] award it's the
hair and makeup people on the farmers
only commercial I don't know how long
they had to go in there and get all the
[ __ ] you know just scrub those
[ __ ] people down and I know this is
coming off as a lead estate liberal
elite elitism but I been to all the
states I've been to most of the cities
I've seen the people white people in the
South are filthy
okay if I was running [ __ ]
instead of building a wall I'd take that
money and I build a giant bathtub and I
would I would say that we got a free
smoker to the first five million people
that show up and when they show
everybody shows up you just you just
push them in the tub before they get out
there all scrubbed up and clean I'm
[ __ ] with you um in Alabama the
people brush their teeth there too I
just like I just like being a dick
anyway anyway I have been doing some
[ __ ] but only fun [ __ ] this weekend for
my Labor Day weekend I am working on my
stand-up act last night had a great
night I went buddy of my and myself went
over to the Rainbow Room classic rocker
club from the 1980s and they had all of
these bands in the 1980s playing in the
parking lot out behind the the [ __ ] is
that place called next door I always
forget the name of that place legendary
place I forget the name of it was at the
anvil it's always something heavy right
I don't know what it was but they had a
stage out back and they had all of these
[ __ ] people and I swear to God his
great is the bands were I think the
people watching was even better I went
there and I felt like I was at my first
concert again except they took that
aging app you know that they do on
social media and just aged everybody 30
years or 33 years that's the last time
when was my first concert 86 and people
still dressed up people still with long
hair and [ __ ] it was just it was [ __ ]
great I just sat there me and my buddy
big smiles on our faces listening to the
music watching all the people the whole
[ __ ] scene at one point someone's
just like who was there
today here on sunset let me see your
hands you know like [ __ ] like 30
people put their hands up and they're
still there flying the flag of metal man
it was great the thing that I've always
loved about the era of music make fun of
it if you want I don't give a [ __ ] they
could [ __ ] play and they could sing
wasn't this auto-tune horseshit no that
would sound like your grandfather here
but I'm telling you they could find they
could still [ __ ] play and Adler's
appetite closed it out so I got to see
Steven Adler played live again one of my
favorite drummers of all time and he
[ __ ] killed it and he was working the
crowd it was awesome it was [ __ ]
awesome and me my buddies had a great
time and then afterwards we rode over to
the or over to the comedy store I jumped
on did a quick set and I'm gonna try to
get out somewhere this week and trying
to do a full hour somewhere here in LA
and just before I get out there and I go
do my my show out in Las Vegas which I'm
really looking forward to getting back
out there and then my special comes out
September 10th so today is the second a
week from today is the ninth that means
a week from tomorrow he's when my
special comes out so old freckles better
start writing now I got my new I got a
new hour [ __ ] that uh that I can say
that is different from everything that
I've done on my special which I'm really
happy about because you know I did all
that acting work this summer so I was
worried about that but I was in New York
City so I got plenty of stage time so I
think I'm ready to go and with that sort
of some you know sad week condolences to
Franco Columbu one of the great
bodybuilders of all time one of the
great physical therapists I actually
went to him a couple of times through
the person that was helping me out with
my shoulder my sciatic issues in my
masseuse was a [ __ ] Jedi was saying
was like in awe of Franco's abilities
saying she always had to like she asked
to touch you to figure out what's wrong
and how Franco could just look at you
and knew what was wrong
she would always shake her head about
his abilities and I went over there and
I was talking to him about how my
shoulder was messed up and for some
reason he was just sitting there
listening to me and I was presenting
theories as to why I thought my shoulder
got [ __ ] up and he just sat there with
this half a smile on his face waited for
me to finish and then told me exactly
what the [ __ ] was wrong with me
gave me this stretch for my pecs which I
kind of stopped doing but immensely
helped me and then I've been and then of
course I fixed my right shoulder then
now my left shoulders got [ __ ] up in
the process so I've been doing his
exercises they taught me and now my left
shoulders getting to where I needed to
be but I only met him a couple of times
but I watched him for years
rest in peace to the great Franco
Columbu and also f2 driver anthony
hubert i hope i said his name right was
killed over the weekend crashed on the
track and then I was Kevin Hart the
great Kevin Hart well-wishes speedy
recovery I should have said he was
alright in case you didn't hear the
story I've got into a car accident I
don't think he was driving either so I
wish him a speedy recovery all right
there we go there we go Jesus not the
bum you out on Labor Day weekend yeah
what are you guys doing you got the big
green egg going huh you got your butcher
block meat still gonna be product
placement although the big green egg has
never [ __ ] the big green egg is never
advertised here and the big red douches
show very surprising to me my big green
egg it [ __ ] her Aldo Rivera thought
he'd make a special about it to see what
was inside of it that's how long it's
been since I cooked on it I just been so
[ __ ] busy it kills me I got to get
that thing cranking up again because as
you know this summer is not over okay
the summer officially ends September
23rd I don't give a [ __ ] what that nerd
said over there in Amsterdam okay when I
look up on the internet when is summer
over it says [ __ ] September 23rd so
I'm sticking with that rather than some
random [ __ ] tall skinny white dude
[ __ ] the Netherlands telling me
what's going on in with this [ __ ]
horseshit Cory look Coriolis effect
whatever the hell he was talking about
so anyway still have not smoked a cigar
Jesus Christ it's not one thing it's
another so I laid off the cigars you
know and now I'm [ __ ] eating M&Ms
it's unreal like I'm not the only one
going through this [ __ ] like at the end
of the day something's got to get me
ramped up
I tried [ __ ] reading tried it it just
you know that's what I need to go back
to reading I got to go back to being
slanders you know I do have some reading
to do I'm actually old freckles is going
for his instrument rating on his his
pilot's license here I'm a couple of
lessons in and I'm having a great time
with that god knows how long that took
me a [ __ ] year to get my private
license how busy I am so I'm working my
way through that [ __ ] and I'm having a
great time doing that I actually bought
this this flight simulator program for
on my computer and then like a little
the only scent like the airplane yoke
you know so I got that with the throttle
so I've been practicing I did my first
precision landing the other day on the
computer it's pretty [ __ ] wild it's
pretty [ __ ] wild but something I've
been wanted to do for a long time when
that guy crashed and killed himself
there in New York
basically it was right diagonally across
the street from where I was staying the
entire summer and I was home when he hit
the [ __ ] building I think I was just
walking out of the apartment I didn't
even hear it and then when we came down
we got in the uber there was a bunch of
people running out into the streets and
allegedly this poor person got
themselves involved in you know they're
trying to beat the weather or something
and I don't know what happened but there
was nothing left of the helicopter and
scared the [ __ ] out of me and I was like
all right I have to kind of face the and
this all goes back to me just [ __ ]
flunking everything in school thinking
that oh then I'm gonna flunk this thing
it's like oh wait a minute I actually
like this subject and I find it
interesting
as opposed to that other [ __ ] was there
anything worse than going into a class
on a subject that just didn't interest
you and then the most uninteresting
monotone person ever would just come in
welcome flange welcome to ancient
medieval history over the next 16 weeks
we're going to explore the wonderful
world of the [ __ ] whatever the Mayans
you know those [ __ ] people who think
the Mayans talked to aliens and [ __ ] and
like but they don't talk about that when
they bring up the Mayans they don't go
into the fun [ __ ] that hey maybe these
guys came here on a spaceship you know
they just stick with facts the boring
[ __ ] facts mess at a pony or whatever
the [ __ ] it is you know it's like please
talk about Pompeii the [ __ ] Mount
Vesuvius in the eruption or some [ __ ] is
that over there I don't know what the
[ __ ] it is all I know my god ancient
medieval history but I actually had a
good ancient medieval history teacher he
was also our football coach in [ __ ]
high school and I'm ever yelled at this
kid in the front row cuz he [ __ ] he
was sick and he was just coughing the
whole [ __ ] class and then finally he
just goes see because he [ __ ] sit in
the back Jesus Christ even if you gotta
come to school you stay home if you're
sick
I don't forget it cuz he had his podium
right in the middle of the cloud was
like like there was so many desks that
he didn't have a lot of room in the
front of the class so his [ __ ] podium
where he was Stan and was basically nose
to nose with this kid in the front row
coughing his [ __ ] brains out he made
him stand up and go all the way to the
back
it was completely warranted nowadays
someone would have filmed that on their
cell phone and he would have been like
six shaming him and he would have got
suspended or got transferred and he
[ __ ] would have had to sell his house
and then it'd be one person going well
hey man if you are six maybe you could
at least wear a mask and then you know
all the Liberals yeah and they'd try to
[ __ ] erase of whatever [ __ ] reason
I have a [ __ ] reason they do that
[ __ ] for so anyway what is this thing
[ __ ] on still we might
it is on right all right it's on it's
just the screen always goes off though
all right I got a couple I got a new
date that I am going to be presenting
that I'm going to be announcing here all
right Washington DC October 5th at the
MGM National haba presale goes on
tomorrow Tuesday at 11 a.m. pre-sales
presale code is Barbie URR and the link
is on Billboard calm or search
Ticketmaster on sale to the general
public this Friday September 6th at 10
a.m. and it's really weird cuz I'm gonna
be performing there on October 5th and
then on October 6th the New England
Patriots are right down the street
playing the [ __ ] Washington Redskins
how weird is that
what it's almost like I'm and it so I
could go to the [ __ ] yeah go to the game
with a bunch of my knucklehead friends
from high school we're starting to do
that we're doing like one road trip a
year and yeah should be a good time
although I'm a little worried that we're
gonna be at Jenks here because back in
the last time we all went to a game was
when we had season tickets in like 1989
you know when we had the little [ __ ]
Paul Revere was on the side you know
that's back when the NFL was crazy you
know he had like Paul Revere we still
have the Redskins right that be oh my
god that'd be a bad game don't get a lot
of [ __ ] this this time this 2019 if we
had some white colonial dude on the side
never why isn't it Christmas the viola
cherry why was you having him on there
alright and then you know the Redskins I
think the Redskins are fine they just
keep riding out like no we're not
changing it we're not changing it and
you've just heard it your whole life so
it just seems fine my only thing is if
they actually change the name please
don't go back to those awful helmets
they had briefly what are they they look
an arrow with like
some [ __ ] fig trees on the side of it
let me see this [ __ ] thing [ __ ]
alternative helmet no not that one that
just has a big R on it not that I say
early 70s [ __ ] vintage helmet
well the [ __ ] was your quarterback there
oh there it is yeah they had a spear
with a [ __ ] that's actually doesn't
look bad that's actually kind of cool if
it's the dark maroon thing that one owes
who knows I'm gonna be going to that
game and I'm assuming we're gonna win
only because the Redskins I don't know
what happened they can't seem to [ __ ]
get it going they can't turn it around
like Ferrari in Formula One can't seem
to turn it around I've been talking all
this shaded bad
they [ __ ] Charles Leclerc won this
week I missed it
I actually was excited to turn it on and
for some reason I liked it all I got was
the time trials but I had the previous
race that was in Hungary so I watched
that one where max Verstappen was
leading the whole race and then Lewis
Hamilton [ __ ] pitted changed [ __ ]
tires and then they I don't know seven
time I said we that's how much I root
against Lewis Hamilton not cuz I don't
like the guy it's just it's the same way
I became a college football fan I can't
root for Alabama you know I'm like me
I'm a Formula one fan who's your
favorite driver Lewis Hamilton oh you
mean the guy who wins all the time I got
a root against you know got to go for an
underdog so when Lewis Hamilton like he
catches up was first happen but he can't
see can't pass him both of them are on
their first set of tires
so they both haven't even wear on them
so Mercedes as always makes the right
move
they have Lewis surprisingly goes in to
the pit right puts on a new pair of
tires and in that moment Max is still
driving opens up like a over 17-second
lead which is enough time
come back around the track pit and then
he gets new [ __ ] tires and they don't
do it so Max has a 17-second lead but he
has like 40 [ __ ] laps left or
30-something laps left next thing you
know it's a 16 second lap lead then it's
15 then it's 14 12 11 10 and then by
then his [ __ ] tires were chewed up
and and Hamilton was picking up like
[ __ ] a second on just like the
backstretch it was inevitable it was
like watching jaws and scenes a
character in the movie that doesn't even
have a name so you know they're gonna
die trying to swim back to the boat that
they just fell back on and they're
[ __ ] playing the John Williams music
bump bump bump bump bump but he [ __ ]
comes in he just passes them and then
that's it then they pit then they pit
because they got a 54 second lead on the
[ __ ] Ferraris so they they at least
you know hold on the second place but I
got it I got if somehow get a maybe go
to the website or something I have to
watch this this last race because it's
always excited to bet the most exciting
thing in Formula One is after turn one
Lewis Hamilton is not in first place
because then you're gonna see some
racing but if he's in first place as
I've said you know but it's not Mercedes
fault it's not their fault that [ __ ]
I don't know I just what whatever
Ferrari did this past week if they could
do that 50% of the [ __ ] time Formula
1 would be the [ __ ] it still is the [ __ ]
I'm just bitching you know I you know
you want to see competition that's all
that's all there is so anyway I did get
a chance to watch that and I guess next
week is the next MotoGP race which if
you want to just see racing on a whole
other level
I know I've been selling the [ __ ] out of
this sport just [ __ ] sign up on their
website you can watch you can watch all
the races all this year every last
[ __ ] one of them get all caught up
and even though with the video so
crashing on that last one wasn't even
his fault kind of solidified it for Marc
Marc
it's still gonna be some great racing
for the rest of the year
all right and with that let's read some
advertising here read some advertising
[Music]
all right manscaped all right support
for the Monday morning podcast comes
from manscaped wait did I say everything
I was supposed to say up here
hang on a second I was supposed to give
you the email oh please remind the
listeners the podcast email is Bill at
the MM podcast.com and by the way we
sent out our first we sent out our first
batches of supplies to the teachers that
wrote in so there you go I did something
so that gives me the right to complain
about every ill in society now because
for one day I took the time to buy some
paper and pens for a teacher
alright manscape support for the Monday
morning podcast comes from manscape who
is number one in men's below-the-belt
grooming manscape offers precision
engineered tools for manscaping with the
right tool for the job talk about the
fear of nicking your ball sack while
manscaping I need to talk about this
like anybody doesn't know that feeling
you know you don't want to get a little
risque and you take the guide off hey
you know and of course that's the night
you lady wants to lick your balls it
happens every time you want her to do it
Nick your balls with your clipper now
it's all over
thanks to manscape emphasizing the
perfect package 2.0 kit that features
the lawnmower 2.0 with skin-safe
technology this trimmer won't nikkor
snag your nuts oh my god is there a
scarier word than snag I mean that's
right up there with rip rip you just
figure you going to shock drop to your
knees with that what the [ __ ] look and
then face plain and then that's it let
me find you with rigor mortis ass in the
air both hands holding your junk with a
stunned look on your face is someone who
got his balls ripped off it's also a 100
percent waterproof so you can use it in
shower don't use the same tremor on your
face that you use on your balls
precision tools for your family jewels
your balls will thank you get 20% off
free shipping and a free travel bag with
the code BER at manscape comm that's
right what you want to do is you want to
you want to trim up your junk the way
you know you ever see what people do
with poodles that's what you want to do
you want to have it puffy around your
dick you know like on the poodles head
and then your balls are like the body
you know and then down around your taint
you give it a little ankle bracelet of
hair somebody somebody's gonna be able
to figure out how to do that there's
enough creative people out there have
you seen the way they do the shape ups
now with the [ __ ] the high-top fades
and the big [ __ ] then they fade the
beard and all of that [ __ ] it's
incredible people put an advertising on
their head you telling me somebody can't
somebody out there look is it challenged
alright you get free tickets a [ __ ]
meet and greet whatever the hell you
want to one of my shows if you buy this
manscape thing and then you trim you
junk the same way that they do for a
poodle it's gonna be at Westminster
alright well maybe maybe you want to
trim it up like they do one of those
shih tzus i don't know pick the breed of
dog i want to see it let's see how
creative i don't want to see that i mean
look at people's dick and balls those
what you got you got a pixelate you junk
out of there yeah yeah this is what
happens when you don't think things
through and you just start talking yeah
I don't give a [ __ ] all right let's just
try to save the public schools forget
the whole [ __ ] poodle junk then it
was a bad idea
alright hellix everybody here's there's
nobody on the planet like you you're
special and no matter how dumb you are
you should put your opinion on social
media so why would you buy a generic
mattress built for everyone else that's
right you know what if you're one of
those people that has boobs and man junk
and you like to sleep on your stomach
you need a special [ __ ] mattress
Helix sleep puts a sleep quiz that takes
a bill to sleep quiz that takes two
minutes to complete and they use the
answers to match your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress
whether you're a sides a hot sleeper
gross like a plush or firm bed with
helix there's no more guessing or
compromising just go to helix sleep calm
/ / take their two minutes sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life four couples helix can even split
the mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side helix sleep
was even awarded that number one best
overall mattress pick of 2019 by GQ and
Wired magazine and CNN called it the
most comfortable mattress they've ever
slept on that they were laying on that
during the last election sorry they have
a ten year warranty and you get to try
it out for a hundred nights risk-free
right now helix health is offering up to
$125 off mattress orders for our
listeners get up to 125 bucks off at
helix sleep calm / / that's helix sleep
calm / / for up to $125 off your
mattress order helic sleep calm / /
helix alright what else do we got here
oh look who it is it's simply simply
safe this is what I wish the whole world
was simply safe it was simple and it was
safe people helped each other on average
a Burghley hat a burglary happens once
every 23 seconds in the United States
when a home security said well there's
[ __ ] over 300-400 [ __ ] million
people how many seconds are in a day
when a home security system is triggered
a lot of the time police assume it's a
false alarm
look at this blaming the cops and call
and the call goes to the bottom of the
list but not with simply safe home
security Silver Efex the police get on
the scene up to 3.5 times faster okay
all of those cops they were just there
loaded for bear yeah that's what you
want because that does happen people put
the [ __ ]
and they don't lock a window the wind
blows and then the [ __ ] alarm comes
on and then the cops are wasting their
time going over to somebody's [ __ ]
house where there's nobody there and
then there's somebody actually in
somebody else's house and they're not
there you got video is the [ __ ]
scumbag he's in my [ __ ] kitchen
simply safe can visually confirm that a
break-in is happening giving police
precise information about where an
intruder is in a home and whether
they're armed so they have all the
information they need to get there
faster and catch a criminal
ASAP as soon as possible simply safe
also protects every door window in room
with 24/7 professional monitoring
there's no contract no hidden fees or
fine print it's won a ton of awards from
a from CNET to the New York Times wire
cutter prices wire cutter sorry prices
are always fair and honest
around-the-clock monitoring starts at
just 15 dollars a month and for my
listeners simply safe has a huge deal
going on right now go to simply saber
comm and get free shipping and a
money-back guarantee that simply safer
calm today simply safe / calm I might
get that because I have an alarm on my
house but I don't have that video that
video verification is [ __ ] great they
should all have that nothing that gets
weird right then do they just turn it on
and watch fan from Greece hey there
Billy boos list freckles yeah by the way
forty weeks in the countdown has begun
two hundred and eighty [ __ ] two days
three sixty eight is my adult record I
was on a great streak from about [ __ ]
I don't know the first 17 years of my
life other than the random sip of beer I
would have I'll never break 17 years
I'll never break that record well let's
see if I were actually to try to do that
I would be 67 68 years old when I
finally did it anyways I'm a big fan of
yours from Greece sorry if my English is
a bit off no what are you talking I
can't speak any Greek you're doing
awesome
all right I've been listening to your
podcast for years and loved your comedy
special specials recently I started
watching f is for family which is also
really good but enough with the
ass-kissing okay that was wondering if
you are ever going to come to Greece for
a show yes I am you toured all over
Europe and then flew over us to go to
Israel and you couldn't stop for a show
here you can't
I think Greece has a big enough audience
for comedy to justify a stop here plus
you could bring the family and have a
great time as a vacation after the show
it's like you said for some other
European country we get the jokes and
understand English but can't speak
English all that well we had Jim
Gaffigan here earlier this year though
he did his show in a terrible a a
meeting room in a hotel yeah but he's
still [ __ ] killed didn't he and then
it'll come back and play an even bigger
place and then you can say I saw money
first [ __ ] came here this summer
louis c.k had a great show here to bla
bla bla bla bla he [ __ ] killed it you
could do you could maybe book in ancient
theatre where they do concerts and [ __ ]
during the summer that's what I plan on
doing that would be awesome
check out the hero died in theatre hope
to see you see one of your shows thanks
- go [ __ ] yourself
and then he wrote his name he says oh I
can't wait to listen you trying to read
that alright
f f thymus hepatitis F Themis you know
what I'm gonna [ __ ] punch this in and
see if I can I can get the actual
spelling acetate acetate the actual
pronunciation has to say
e F th Y here we go
e f th y mi s Jesus Christ in this
[ __ ] mustachioed lunatic I forgot to
write pronunciation pronunciation how to
pronounce okay here we go here we go
here it comes
pronounce names com
females females females thank you for
the email in theme EOS alright pronounce
names comm hey shut up all right I got
it we got it if demeo's thank you with
demeo's i will be over there at some
point anyway I had a rough weekend as a
[ __ ] parrot man my daughter got an
ear infection so I feel bad about that
and then also over the summer time I
went to I went to Coney Island and I
[ __ ] up and I took her on a ride I
thought it was a kid ride and was an
adult ride and once it started there was
nothing was the first time she was
freaking out and I couldn't help her and
I just had to hold her until it was over
and she used to love going on the swing
and now she doesn't like going on the
swing it makes her stomach drop she gets
all nervous so you know I felt terrible
like she says instead of saying it's not
fun she goes not funny not funny swing
not funny and I'm like man so what I did
was I just pushed her slow and I was
just going okay what colors daddy's
shirt she was like clean all right what
colors daddy sneakers she'd be like
white and I'd be like and whoa
right so I was able to get it a little
bit a little bit faster but I definitely
saw that I gave her a little bit of a
complex and a fear thing and which I
mean I think it's impossible to be a
parent and a [ __ ] but I felt horrible
and then you know she was complaining
about her ear we didn't realize she got
a little bit of water in her ear so now
every time she goes swimming which by
the way she's killing it she actually
like enjoys swimming underwater more
than she does above water it's hilarious
she has like absolutely no fear and
she's they have no fear when she was on
the swing going faster faster so she's
so early on I think I can get her out of
it but I felt terrible about not
noticing that you know she's mentioned
something about her ear and then a day
later we figured out what was going on
but now we have the medicine so now
she's
better but like you just feel like such
a [ __ ] [ __ ] we just like my kid
was in pain and I didn't realize it but
I mean they also don't have the the
words to tell you that but she's better
now she's hanging with their mom but
when I am proud of she's like ridiculous
has no fear swimming all she uses now
just as one of those little tube like
foam floaters and she's got her arm
going now all she needs to do now is
just know how to hold her head up above
the water but she's so into like blowing
bubbles and being underwater my wife
gave her tea for breakfast the other day
because she likes it it's [ __ ]
hilarious
and she got down towards the end of it
and just went just really hard blue
bubbles and I went all over her face and
hair and everything and she thought it
was hilarious of course they had to go
clean enough but everything now is
blowing bubbles and being under the
water and she loves it so that someone
told me you know what the doctor said
when they get out of the pool if you
just take a little bit of alcohol on a
q-tip and kind of swab the inside of
their ear that usually is enough to do
it but your course also scares the [ __ ]
out of me because I don't want to
[ __ ] you know never turn our head you
all you ever do is just think of the
[ __ ] worst-case scenarios like I'm
gonna take her skating soon and I'm
getting our hockey gloves because I
don't want her to fall down on the ice
and then somebody's you know skate over
I know I know right I don't need I don't
even need to say it but that's all you
Theo you play is one [ __ ] Friday the
13th Jason Voorhees [ __ ] moment in
your head over and over again but I'm
gonna take her [ __ ] skating soon I
also when I was in New York I was
renting bikes that had the little kids
seat on the back and she [ __ ] loved
that so I'm gonna buy a bike with one of
those which I have to do soon while
she's still you know she's big enough to
do it but like they just passed through
these windows where all you you had that
moment to do this thing and then they're
too big you know she's growing like a
weed she's super [ __ ] tall it's
amazing so that's why I'm so thankful
that I have been to other than my
stand-up gigs I have the entire fall off
I'm not doing anything so we've been
having a great
and I got this book daddy/daughter dates
you know I think this one else has a
little religious thing in there which is
slightly annoying but they're great
ideas you know obvious ones go out for
ice cream or pizza or something like
that then they just have some good ones
but I was looking through a lot I'm like
go on a bike ride it's like I did that
you know go back horseback riding I did
that go on a little choo-choo train I've
done that you know take it to the park
I've done all of those merry-go-rounds
all of that stuff so I'm trying to do
just do as much fun stuff with her as I
can because they grow up so damn fast
and then they leave that's the thing is
they leave they move out one day and
then you lose your buddy so you just got
a [ __ ] you know I got one of my
friends his kid just went off to college
and he's just like dude I can't believe
how [ __ ] up I am you know so I'm like
alright well I got that coming that's in
the future but I can't stop that day
from coming but uh I can't have as much
fun with her as I can while she's still
living at home so that's it I'm very
thankful that I know that when she's
only two and a half not another
advantage of being an old debt is that
all the dad's you raise you don't do
what I'm telling you cause myself ah
gross
all right here we go follow up from the
Monday morning pod follow up from Monday
about reuniting with the strange father
are all right here we go
here we go we're going back this is a
two-parter
all right dear bill I'm a huge Scottish
lady fan I don't miss the way I said
that it made me seem like she was fed
I'm a huge Scottish lady fan lady fan I
don't miss an episode of you on or off
camera and recently saw you in Glasgow
thank you for fulfilling a bucket-list
gig for me by coming back to Scotland I
love Scotland Scotland I wanted that was
my bed Scottish accent I always have to
do it once everybody Oh full Caruso now
go [ __ ] yourself you rainy [ __ ]
I wanted to reply to the lady wondering
whether to get in touch with her
estranged father on her podcast from
Monday August 26th all right she said
please
don't do it you'd be putting his needs
before your own you've got on with your
life this far without him and do not
need that negativity in your life yeah
this is the guy who now because he's
gonna die and he feels guilty is what it
seemed like to me he wanted to reach out
I have a similar situation with my
mother
she's always put her men before myself
and my siblings and most and her most
recent husband was abusive to us as a
result we've all walked away from her
and have gone on to lead happier lives
we were given a small fright a couple
years ago when we were misinformed she
had passed away we wondered if the shock
was a wake-up call and should we make
amends
then we recovered and truly realized we
could never take the chance in accepting
this manipulative horrible woman back
into our lives what she faked her death
or something her husband is now deceased
and she has since tried to go into my
brother's place of work to try and bump
into him all such attempts from her will
be knocked back she's not a nice person
was a terrible mother especially if
there was a man in her life and we do
not want her in our lives and will
continue to live happily without her all
right you know in defense of the woman
wanting to see her dad possibly uh you
haven't given any reason why she all
you're doing is talking about you so
you're superimposing your experience
which everybody's different but I guess
that's all you can go with is what you
know
therefore please please please do not
grant your father's wishes he could live
for many years and poison those years of
your life walk away you'll be so much
happier for it you can choose your
friends and not your family I have many
friends I now consider my family which I
am sure you do too and I do not missing
having a mother in the slightest hope
this helped
xxxxX please best regards um yeah I
think it all comes down to you know your
own decision my one of my favorite
opinions on that was the joke that Joe
DeRosa had where Joe was talking about
being adopted and he goes people always
come up to me go do you ever like you
know do you ever want to go meet your
real parents do you ever have like a
desire do you ever want to go you know
see where they are you want to do that
then he just goes no you know I kind of
took the hint when they abandoned me Joe
DeRosa Joe DeRosa ladies and gentlemen
Joe DeRosa he actually recently was on
Bobby Kelley's podcast and I saw a clip
of that on Instagram and it was it was
[ __ ] hilarious bob was trying to get
him to say this super positive mantra
which Joe did repeated a number of times
before Joe went jelf brought some
reality into the end of the whole
[ __ ] thing alright budgeting question
dear Billy the banker I'm a 29 year old
lady and I graduated college last
December congratulation I worked hard
and found a great job immediately good
for you I can comfortably pay my bills
and put money away in savings now this
is a scenario you don't hear that often
from these kids who would graduate in
college these days it seems anyway she
says I picked up a side gig tutoring
kids to earn extra money to put into
savings things are going pretty well ah
gee whatever you do don't don't [ __ ]
start dating some freeloading douche who
wants to take your money and invest it
in his idea alright here's my question I
grew up really poor in the South here
here come the relatives I survived with
my single mother living off welfare and
charity donations I worked hard and had
a job since I was 13 I put myself
through college and now occasionally
help my mom out financially
understandable my problem is I've been
saving to the point that I now have a
little extra stored and I really want to
go
on a real vacation with my partner but
spending money scares me you know that's
not that's not a bad thing that's better
than being the other way where you just
you know it just slips through your
fingers this is exactly how I was with
money for different reasons
you know I saw you know I grew up in the
70s gas crisis you know economic crunch
and [ __ ] and I had friends whose parents
had real jobs and they lost the jobs and
they lost the houses they had to move
away and you know as a pair to my family
had to downsize like I just you just saw
it at a young age that oh [ __ ] can go
the [ __ ] doesn't just [ __ ] does not stay
the same [ __ ] moves so i'ma when I moved
to New York City I was afraid to take a
taxicab
like maybe twice a month I would take a
cab and I couldn't believe the luxury of
it I'd finish up down the village and
take a cab all the way uptown back when
they drove like lunatics they're
starting to drive like lunatics again
but Giuliani slowed him down but they
used to have the way they had the lights
timed is you could just [ __ ] go from
like basically you know 8th Street up to
about 79 80th Street before you know
just too many people got in front of you
and you missed the light you just be
within this pocket of green lights the
whole way up and I remember it would
just be such a luxury to do it and then
afterwards I would get out of the cab
and I would feel so [ __ ] guilty and I
would never order out for food I just
yeah I just held on to every [ __ ]
dime because I didn't know what was
gonna happen
even though yeah I always had this thing
in the short-run
I was white knuckling freaking out every
[ __ ] move I was making but in the long
run I had this confidence in knew I was
gonna be alright it was weird so anyways
she says ok my problem is I've been
saving to the point I have enough money
to go on a vacation but
money scares me I have an emergency fund
as well as a separate savings account
for if a recession hits and I was out of
work for a few months wait for the
recession hits and I was out of work for
a few months okay you weren't out of
work this is just in case see this is
the way this is the way like a
responsible person handles money and
then you don't become a debt to society
this is where the government should be
running this country but they don't and
then when they [ __ ] up somehow then they
come to people who responsibly handed
their money and say we have to take more
your [ __ ] money and that's a guy well
what the [ __ ] are you guys doing you
know I'm balanced in my budget you can't
do the same [ __ ] thing paying nine
million dollars more than you should be
to these [ __ ] [ __ ] get the
government contracts alright let's not
making it about yourself don't sorry
alright growing up so poor made me as
made me respect money and fear being
without it it's a hell of an education I
live modestly and below my means but I
think it's time I do something for
myself is that selfish look at that yeah
it's like me taking the cab how do you
go about spending money on a vacation or
an expensive purchase and not feel
guilty my partner says I deserve to
relax a little and even my manager says
I should take some time off what do you
think all the best - the lovely Nia and
the little one go [ __ ] yourself I think
they're right and I think I don't think
like this is going to be like hitting
the crack pipe like you're gonna go on a
three-day [ __ ] vacation and then all
of a sudden just come back and start
buying [ __ ] gold chains and stupid
[ __ ] this is what I what I have learned
late in my adult life is the importance
of taking time off the importance of
taking a vacation the importance of
quiet time and the amount of you know
restart recharging your batteries and
then you can come back and be even
better at your job and become even more
six
you have to [ __ ] do it all right the
old me I would have come right out of
this [ __ ] acting gig all summer long
and gone right hardcore on the road said
yes to a thousand [ __ ] things you
know I I did that a little bit but once
I saw this free time I was like oh I can
get my instrument rating but it but
that's fun and enjoyable but I think
it's it's huge huge is what used to is
scheduled in you know a copy this is you
can you don't have to [ __ ] go to you
know the ends of the world to go on
vacation you know what's really
underrated not only a stay vacation
which I don't think you should do I
think you should go somewhere just
taking a vacation a lakes are the [ __ ]
just hanging out getting a little
[ __ ] cabin and it doesn't I mean lay
a lake is a [ __ ] lake so you can find
a cheap [ __ ] place and you know you
with your partner having a great time
get some food if I have a couple of
beers just [ __ ] hang out you go to
the grocery store and just buy burgers
and dogs chill the [ __ ] out laugh your
ass up play cards don't watch TV shut
off your phone if you did that for three
days you'd be amazed what that did for
you and it wouldn't even cost that much
money and then as you get more and more
successful you know or if you have a
place you really wanted to go on a
vacation just start saving towards that
and save way more than you need and and
then go on that vacation but I think you
had no pun intended a priceless
upbringing and it's great to hear a
young person that has this type of
viewpoint on money and that's a great
way to be it's always better and like
all like my grandparents were like that
because they lived through a depression
they were incredible incredible with
money both sets of grandparents weren't
with money they just you know first of
all that aside from going through the
depression there was also repairment
back in the day and if you TV broke you
got it fixed you didn't just [ __ ]
throw it out there wasn't this design
obsolescence is that the word that they
have with all of this [ __ ] where you
just accept the fact that that things
are going to break and then you don't
even you don't even entertain getting it
fixed you just throw it out you know
unfortunately was a business right down
on Sunset and like vine it was
somebody's camera shop and I drove by it
the other day and I was on the way to
the movies when I saw the great Quentin
Tarantino movie which I'm gonna see
again this week I cannot stop thinking
of two things I haven't stopped thinking
about last week that delicious cigar
that I smoked and that movie and anyway
I there was a camera shop that went out
of business there's a couple of small
businesses that broke my heart that went
out of business that one did and cascade
Studios went out of business that's
where I played drums for the better part
of 12 years I would go down there and
they hooked me up they would give me the
showcase room and all of that stuff and
they just treated me like gold whenever
I was there and I just want to give a
shout out to Joe Laterza
who ran the place had such a great time
going down there and you know they built
this giant apartment building next door
and you just knew the writing was on the
wall something was gonna happen they and
they [ __ ] race the rent through the
[ __ ] roof and it was this really cool
warehouse looking thing that had train
tracks that went right up to the back of
it like I guess back in the day before
they ripped up all the train tracks
these trains would pull right up I think
with whatever load and unload stuff
right on the dock and that was actually
the way the main studio was but uh I
mean it was a legit studio I remember
even at one time and Billy Idol was in
there with his band Steve Stevens at all
these [ __ ] monster players remember
sneaking a peek in trying not to get in
trouble but just listening to a
professional band rehearsing was just
[ __ ] amazing and then I would be down
the hall paradiddle paradiddle
paradiddle like a [ __ ] idiot
cascade studios
rest in peace man that was a great one I
hope Joe gets a chance to open up a
place somewhere else because once again
one of the things that's happening out
here in LA is just so many awesome
places where it's a place to go and do
something get swallowed up by just I
don't know these apartment complexes
there's gonna be nothing to do I guess
whether they know they get ready for the
virtual reality glasses or you don't
have to go outside I don't know go back
to that little lady get a virtual
reality glasses of [ __ ] grease then
you can save your money you have to go
on a vacation don't don't do that okay
all right next one next one coming up
here what do we got here Oh Patrice
hello Billie red face bill I've been a
fan of comedy for a while now and I have
to say that one of the greatest
comedians of all time has to be Patrice
O'Neal that's the best comic I ever saw
a life ever just as far as you had no
idea what was gonna happen I've talked
about him at Millington you know I feel
about him I remember you saying that one
of the most defining moments of the
Patrice legacy is when he was able to
riff off riff off a trans person on the
street corner trading insult oaks oh
yeah I know they started giving each
other [ __ ] yeah back and forth for like
an hour
you compared it to the moment when
biggie was freestyling on the corner and
there was just this talent that was
undeniable yeah he was out in front of
the cellar and whatever you're supposed
to call the person I don't know if it
was a dude dressed like a woman or dude
transitioning but the dude came walking
by and Patrice teased her and she
immediately turned around and started
giving him [ __ ] and then just this
circle immediately formed and it was
just Ali Frazier and she had like a lot
of like
the people having heard this story she
had a lot of like you know classic like
street jokes they wasn't really her
material like you got so much space
between your teeth looks like your
tongues in jail like it's the classic
snaps I believe people of
african-american descent called him then
Patrice just [ __ ] rope the dope he
just kind of stayed on the ropes let her
get all their [ __ ] memorized jokes
out of the way it wasn't that for like
an hour it was like it it felt like 20
minutes it was probably only like six
seven minutes but it was [ __ ]
unbelievable it was unreal I was just I
didn't know what was gonna happen so
anyways he said when you spoke about it
you can tell there was a real admiration
as you were in the presence of a comedy
great yeah because it was all the
loudmouth comics none of us shut up we
were all trying to top each other we all
shut up and became a crowd and watched
this just whatever the [ __ ] he's
supposed to I don't know I don't know
you're supposed to say they were called
transvestites when I was a kid right
watched her try to go for Patrice's
title and come out throwing haymakers
not afraid whatsoever the thing is we
all knew Patrice and knew what he could
do so we were afraid so this woman not
knowing Patrice was not afraid and it
was it was working it was like Duke in
the first quarter playing Alabama she
forced a fumble right so anyways he says
I still listen to his guest appearances
on Opie and Anthony that is probably the
best if you want to know anything about
him what it was like to be around and
that it's the closest thing to all those
old Owen aid clips he says I listened to
it about once a month on YouTube and I'm
always mind blown at his razor-sharp
timing and honesty not too long ago I
watched the live podcast you made and it
reminded me of Patricia's skill level
well laughs Jesus that's as high a
compliment as it as it comes but no I
was nowhere near him also I've had the
advantage of continuing to practice
for another seven years you know he was
at least ten years ahead of all of us I
mean unfortunately I can't believe it
but this November 29th he's been gone
already for eight years so anyways he
goes I think you guys are on such an
elite level of comedic delivery at this
point that it must be for a new
comedians how you guys probably looked
at Carlin or Pryor or maybe even Hicks
the craft has come a long way yeah I
don't know like those are some big names
they're my only thing about young comics
is I just hope that they don't ever look
at Carlin and Pryor and those guys the
way when I heard that rapper saying that
Biggie Smalls was overrated I was just
like and that really depressed me like
you know I don't know it's just like
when someone as great as that comes
along and then everybody goes in steals
from their style then they end up making
the original not look as good as they
were like I don't think anybody was
stolen more from than Richard Pryor I
mean we all got something from that guy
[Music]
and I remember comics you know when
Carlin was towards the end they were
saying stupid things like oh he's just
or an angry old man now a ba ba ba ba ba
ba yeah now go back and watch those
[ __ ] specials he was warning
everybody what was coming and he was
100% [ __ ] right it's just one of the
things that comes with being ahead of
the curve is people who are basic don't
see it and then they actually think that
not only is the person not good they
actually think in their own [ __ ] a
hacky mind that they are doing that
they're performing on the same level
anyways he goes sometimes I like to
imagine the type of damage Patrice with
doing something like the Joe Rogan
experience or even his own puck he did
have a podcast Oh him and Jill Rogan
that would be that would have been that
would have been unbelievable the two of
them in the same room his passing was a
major loss to comedy and I wish he was
more recognized well
well we're gonna be doing a little bit
something I can't announce the project
but we're when the works lead the heat
as long as I'm around people will hear
is that guy's name and Bobby Kelly like
we always bring him up and thank God
Opie and Anthony in Jim Norton had him
on this show and that video exists but
like he is he's timeless I don't see
people not knowing who he is
anyways I was hoping you could share a
story we may have not heard thus far
about the legendary Patrice O'Neal and
if you can see anyone else coming up
with that similar energy also one more
thing if you have the time I'd like to
know your personal Mount Rushmore of of
comedy would look like best regards to
your family and go [ __ ] yourself my
Mount Rushmore
well Mount Rushmore is like what is that
for people what is it Washington Lincoln
Jefferson and Teddy Roosevelt Teddy
Roosevelt being he was the standing
president I think that's why he got in
there all right well my Mount Rushmore
Pryor Carlin I can't just do four
prior and Karlin everybody has and of
course Lenny Bruce Joan Rivers brutally
brutally brutally underrated I put her
like at Carlin's level as far as just
the sheer volume of material that she
wrote and and level of balls like the
end of her life she was still in jokes
that would be I still wouldn't have the
balls to do just an absolute beast
of a comic yeah this dis too many Sam
Kinison Eddie Murphy and then there's
then I have like my mini mount
Rushmore's of people that I just saw
that affected my career like I can't say
many but like my other mount my subset
of the Mount Rushmore like the three
sets that four sets that I saw growing
up five signals too many this just too
many first time I saw Brian Regan seeing
Jill Rogan and Aspen in the early 2000s
seeing this comic Frankie Bastille who
since passed away first time I ever saw
a comic just talking on stage was him I
saw Frank Santorelli at the old comic
comedy connection he went on stage and
they were playing music and the host
won't this woman was dancing and then
Frank just started dancing behind her
with this super intense look on his face
and it just I don't know I just think it
just it was almost like when Pryor
walked on stage and not everybody wasn't
seated so he started riffing and he just
caught this zone and it never ended I
saw I saw Santa relly do that just
absolutely [ __ ] wire-to-wire murder
so David Feldman in that same room
there's just too many there's literally
there's too many first time I saw Dave
Attell Louie Greer Barnes
Brian Holtzman dice I'm gonna forget
somebody that's why I can't do this
there's too many there's just too
[ __ ] many people that I saw and then
of course Patrice a million [ __ ]
times yeah there's just there is there's
too many too many [ __ ] people that I
learned from so let's see a Patrice
story that nobody knows about I never
tell you the pineapple story can't mind
if I told that one he was staying at my
apartment during pilot season in the
late 90s and he come out there and we
both trying to book a pilot both of us
miserable cuz we just wanted to be on
stage doing jokes but you know that's
what it was it was must-see TV on NBC
and all these comics were getting
sitcoms all these come by all these
comics I mean half a dozen that made it
to syndication and that was the [ __ ]
pipe dream everybody was chasing so
management your agent well you got to
get out of here for pilot season you get
on something and then then you'll you'll
you'll get famous and then you'll sell
tickets and yet did that then I'll let
[ __ ] and in the back of our heads we
both knew or you just become such a good
comic that you know you just build it up
by just being funny and you know
whatever I don't know so this is before
podcasting and the internet blowing up
in social media and all this [ __ ] so we
were out there for podcasts Eze and
Patrice loved to cook and I don't he
bought this [ __ ] pineapple and I came
home and he had this look on his face I
came walking in and you know my kitchen
was right there to the right and I see
that the top of the pineapple sticking
out of the garbage disposal and Patrice
had this look on his face like I'm sorry
man i de [ __ ] tried to stick the
whole [ __ ] pineapple down there
and it was towards the end of pilot
season and just having even your best
friend be a guest for that lawn was
becoming annoying and I remember just
looking at my cheese's Carla the [ __ ]
tree we got this [ __ ] argument about
it
and then he got mad at me for getting
mad and I was just like then go it's
like [ __ ] wood why would you put it
down there and it was all so it wasn't
that I was mad at him it's just that I
lived in this shitty [ __ ] apartment
and the Landlord was just never [ __ ]
helped in fact he they stole out of my
apartment that's where the [ __ ] I was
living so we're never getting this big
[ __ ] argument as I always did when I
was young I always got mad and [ __ ] I
[ __ ] used to fight with him and
bobbing all the time then we'd [ __ ]
we could be friends again in like 40
minutes literally like little kids in a
[ __ ] sandbox
I just never forgot the [ __ ] look on
his face and that stupid top of the
[ __ ] things sticking out of the
garbage disposal and I should have just
laughed as mostly in life I should have
just laughed
I didn't and and I think he always found
that puzzling about me because he never
really got mad and I would get mad but
then also I didn't really sabotage
myself and he would sabotage himself but
then when he would see me trying to go
for something he would then just trash
me and try to make me second-guess it so
he could only you know as I got like a
[ __ ] townie like stay here you know
and I'd like [ __ ] we are man we were
so [ __ ] it was so funny when we were
young to me Bobby and Patrice were so
great and so awful for each other
because we loved each other we were so
supportive but we were so [ __ ] up from
our childhoods but we didn't understand
that we were you know it was all pre
therapy free self analysis of all of
that I think the trees everywhere the
[ __ ] therapy but yeah we mean women
Bobby were living together we used to
play [ __ ] roller hockey we used to
almost get into like a [ __ ] fistfight
every single time and like we'd go back
to the apartment and then like four
[ __ ] 20 minutes wouldn't be talking
to each other and then like somewhere
he would always think he knew I depart
then I'm [ __ ] sad you know what are
we doing the blah blah the next thing
would be [ __ ] laughs and ordering
food then it would be fine but like yeah
I was an angry young man when I was in
my 20s
regrettably I know you guys probably
throw still think I'm angry but I wasn't
I'm aware that I'm angry now which is so
much better than just being angry and
not even [ __ ] being aware of it so so
there you go there's the pineapple story
and I look back and regret like I should
have just [ __ ] laughed it off and
called him a [ __ ] dope but we could
have laughed about it just but it's like
Bill this pineapple skin in a garbage
disposal they could figure it out all
right Iranian looking for love advice it
sounds like a new [ __ ] Netflix series
all right hi Bill the love BRR
I was wondering if you and the lovely
Mia it's Neal with an end not M can help
me I'm looking for some romantic advice
I live in a small town I'm not gonna say
where over there and I ran right on the
border of Iran in this other country
I've been wanting to ask a girl for a
long time but I don't know if she likes
me or not
[ __ ] it man it's only way in Iran if you
want to ask a girl out first you have to
get friendly with her you just can't go
up to the girl and ask her out that
would be very disrespectful okay I kind
of get that all right I know this girl
at least for three years and I like her
very much but every time I tried to talk
to her she either ignored me or answered
me very formal formally so I got the
signal and stopped trying to be friends
and started using the plural pronouns
when referring to her using parentheses
using a plural pronoun for somebody is a
sign of respect in Farsi in the formal
way of speaking I hope I said that right
in quote and started talking to her very
formally then she started answering me
very friendly and always smiles when I'm
talking to her
I am very confused now well maybe you
just came off as too familiar
or maybe she's playing hard to get I
don't know a woman's a woman they like
doing that I am very confused now I
don't know what I should do should I ask
her out or not because I really like
this girl and she's been giving me mixed
signals now dude the key point is you
switched your pronouns stay with the
form of pronouns treated respectful so
she knows you're a gentleman if you're a
gentleman as long as you're a gentleman
do that anyways I don't want to bother
if she's not interested no that's not
what it is you're afraid of rejection
and we are classmates in college so if I
ask around she says no to me every class
this year will be awkward for me why
would it be awkward
I liked you you didn't like me back who
gives a [ __ ] I put it out there and then
still just be friendly to her you know
what she'd find that attractive the fact
that you could actually handle it and
then not be weird around her you can
even have that conversation just come up
to her use your former pro pronouns or
whatever and just be a listen I know I
asked you I just still wanted to be
weird all right
we're cool while we cool great well cool
okay well whatever just well how do you
do it in your culture just do that
anyways he says do I ask her out or not
if I should ask her out
how should I ask her out should I text
her should I DM her please guide me the
redheaded bald-headed wise King and the
wise ebony Queen and sorry for the bad
English nah dude man the [ __ ] up listen
she's smiling she's giving you the
signal she came on a little strong a
little too familiar now you're using the
form of things so she's a classy chick
there you go I would ask her out you
know what the great thing about asking
her out the rest of life you don't have
to have regret of I should have so just
do it you know if she says yes you're in
the game if she isn't who gives a [ __ ]
now you know she's not into you you can
get on with you [ __ ] life alright
just always be respectful that's it
that's it keep using those pronouns
alright now make yourself proud
the worst thing is she says no and now
you have a funny story to tell that's
the worst thing that happened who gives
a [ __ ]
alright overrated underrated alright
underrated early morning weather this
time of year it's like waiting for the
school bus weather the temperature
slowly Rises from the time you leave
your house to the time you get on the
bus I have another underrated the Sunday
paper I bought one yesterday had a
little quiet time I just sat there and
read like the front section of the
newspaper was great
yeah the Sunday paper underrated
overrated communication did any of it
ever really need to be said
probably not oh Jesus somebody had a bet
no communication is great and yeah it
needs to be said not if you're going to
insult somebody but if you're telling
somebody how you feel yeah it doesn't
need to be said but just did any of it
ever really need need to be said
probably not you sound a little
emotionally shutdown I relate to that
what you just wrote there that seems
like how I was a long [ __ ] time ago
and I can tell you it doesn't work out
no man is an island all right say what
you think could get out there take a
goddamn chance just like that guy the
Iranian guy who's gonna walk into the
class he's got a man the [ __ ] up you
know I can't do it over diem a text
message she's gonna tell you kids that
so what did you say when you first met
your mother uh nothing I was too afraid
to so I sent her a [ __ ] email ba-bump
ba-bump ow maybe like my dad has no
balls all right um well I got a question
for you Iranian person where do I buy
one of those [ __ ] things that you
guys wear over there because it's
getting hot as [ __ ] over here with
global warming you know what do you call
that what do you call the outfit then
you put like the thing on your head and
then you just you just rest that little
halo on you it's perfect I'm gonna get
one of those except I won't wear it down
south
it's one of them red hustle redheaded
Muslims actually I'm Catholic just
trying to avoid a sunburn anyway alright
that's it that's it for the [ __ ]
podcast I just plugged the thing and
hope that didn't [ __ ] this thing up
I just mentally left the podcast have a
great couple of days I'll check in on ya
on Thursday